la parole et commerciaux nous aviez
breton merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre nous sommes
de plus en plus nombreux à nous opposer
à la gestation par autrui la gpa est
contraire à la dignité des femmes qui
louent leur ventre la gpa est contraire
à la dignité des enfants conçus comme
des choses qui peuvent être donnés ou
vendus
et pourtant vendredi dernier la cour de
cassation a légalisé de fait la gpa en
validant la transcription des actes de
naissance des enfants nés d'une mère
porteuse à l'étranger
en aucun cas cette décision ne peut se
justifier en invoquant l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant non un enfant né
de gpa à l'étranger n'est absolument pas
privé d'identité
il n'est pas apatride il a bien une
filiation et il a un acte de naissance
étranger qui est pris en compte dans la
vie courante
par contre où l intérêt supérieur de
sept enfants
quand il fait l'objet d'un contrat quand
son abandon a été programmée et quand sa
filiation et mensongères malheureusement
loin de s'opposer à la gpa
les arrêts de la cour de cassation
constitue un encouragement à violer
délibérément la loi française est
exploité honteusement des mères
porteuses à l'étranger avec la
bénédiction de notre droit la lâcheté
serait de prendre simplement acte de ces
décisions de justice
il est temps au contraire de sortir de
l'hypocrisie et d'engager une démarche
claire et courageuse pour interdire tout
recours une mère porteuse
aussi bien en france qu'à l'étranger et
pour demander au niveau international
l'abolition universelle de la gpa
alors monsieur le premier ministre
etes-vous enfin décidée à adopter cette
démarche claire et courageuse contre la
gpa afin que notre pays assure à nouveau
la protection des femmes dont le corps
est exploité et la protection des
enfants considérés comme une vulgaire
marchandise
la parole est à madame christiane
taubira garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
aviez breton c'est un sujet lourd c'est
un sujet difficile c'est un sujet
délicat
il est quand même regrettable que vous
ayez achever votre propos en traitant
les enfants de marchandises tu ne parles
et d'autre part sur tout en prétendant
en prétendant nouveau présent dans 2 en
prétendant que ne pas leur reconnaître
un état civil claire établi consisterait
à les protéger
nous pensons que ces enfants endroits
des protections parce que ce sont des
enfants français sont les enfants de
france ce sont les futurs citoyens de ce
pays vous porter une appréciation très
critique sur des décisions de la cour de
cassation
c'est votre liberté encore que je doute
que ce soit votre droit parce que dans
l' équilibre d'une démocratie et un état
de droit la séparation des pouvoirs
suppose que chaque institution respecte
les autres et la décision la cour de
cassation constitue une jurisprudence
qui se posent en notre pays et la
jurisprudence est une façon saine de
régler des problèmes de société qui sont
difficiles
la cour de cassation ne remet pas en
cause l'interdît absolu de la gestation
pour autrui
pas plus d'ailleurs que la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme ne met
en cause cet interdit absolu sur la
gestation pour autrui les engagements de
la france notamment à travers la place
signature et la ratification de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme
ces engagements font que nous devons
protéger les enfants mais au delà même
de ses engagements internationaux
l'histoire du droit de la famille en
france protège les enfants
donc nous allons continuer à affirmer
fortement le principe d'interdiction
absolue de la gestation pour autrui
mais pour autant nous ne serons pas
indifférent au sort des enfants
qui sont nés qui existe et dans l'acte
de naissance et régulier régulièrement
établis à l'étranger comme le prob la
cour de cassation
si madame lag